Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Mi occupo di geopolitica.
Non vi annoierò con trattati
su che cos'è la geopolitica.
Fortunatamente,
o sfortunatamente, per noi,
va molto di moda oggi:
tutti se ne occupano, tutti ne parlano.
Ma resta una disciplina quasi esoterica.
Serve stabilire,
prima che ci addentriamo
nelle mie chiacchiere di oggi,
che la geopolitica
è lo studio dei conflitti
in uno spazio geografico.
Detto in maniera ancora più semplice,
la geopolitica non è lo studio
delle relazioni internazionali
in quanto tali.
Ma serve a riconoscere le costrizioni
che poi obbligano
gli attori internazionali
a muoversi in una certa maniera.
È una disciplina antipatica,
come potete immaginare, per eccellenza
perché si concentra sugli obblighi.
E oggi, con questa impostazione
vi parlerò di globalizzazione.
Proveremo a capire
che cos'è la globalizzazione,
altro tema gigantesco
che va più o meno di moda.
C'è chi l'ama: non moltissimi;
chi la odia: molti di più.
Proveremo a capire che cos'è, in realtà,
qual è il suo sostrato strategico,
per poi intuire a che punto è,
quanto può durare,
e soprattutto se si tratta o meno
di un fenomeno inedito.
Sul piano geopolitico,
questa che vedete alle mie spalle -
quindi sono coerente con quanto
vi ho appena detto:
la geopolitica dev'essere
sul territorio, sullo spazio.
Tutto ciò di cui discutiamo
dev'essere cartografabile.
Queste sono carte
della rivista per cui lavoro,
la rivista "Limes", di geopolitica.
Su questa carta
in particolare, che vedete,
con dizione altisonante,
cioè "Impero Americano".
L'impero, in geopolitica,
non ha un'accezione positiva o negativa:
esiste in quanto tale.
E spesso anche contro la volontà
di chi ne è parte:
probabilmente, gli americani
non volevano costruire un impero.
Eppure ce l'hanno, l'hanno fatto,
e come sempre, in questi casi,
se lo tengono e moriranno da impero.
Chissà quando: gli auguriamo
il più tardi possibile, per loro.
Ma quella che vediamo,
che ci interessa di più su questa carta,
è la globalizzazione.
Cioè, la globalizzazione è tutta qui.
Se chiedessimo -
in Italia va molto di moda -
a persone che non si occupano
di questioni strategiche
di intervenire su una questione strategica
come la globalizzazione -
anzitutto gli economisti, che in Italia
vanno particolarmente di moda -
vi racconteranno che la globalizzazione
è quella situazione, e quella condizione,
in cui gli scambi commerciali
avvengono in un unico mercato globale.
Forse, se volessimo condire questo assunto
con una disposizione di tipo ideologico,
aggiungeremmo anche che lo fanno
perché mediamente si vogliono bene,
o comunque esiste una predisposizione
tutta umana al commercio.
Il problema è che manca
il principio di causalità,
in un'affermazione come questa.
Come nasce la globalizzazione?
Perché esiste? Quanto dura?
Quella che vedete raffigurata
su questa carta
è la divisione in flotte,
da parte della marina statunitense,
del planisfero.
Cioè come il Pentagono,
per essere molto semplici,
guarda al planisfero,
e come lo divide in base alle competenze
delle proprie flotte.
Perché, ed entriamo
nel vivo della questione,
la globalizzazione che viviamo
non è nient'altro che il controllo
dei mari e degli oceani
da parte degli Stati Uniti d'America.
Proprio nient'altro!
Nel suo telaio,
la globalizzazione è tutta qui.
Perché questo?
Perché oggi, quindi nel 2019,
non 100 anni fa,
il 90 percento delle merci
che si muovono sulla Terra
viaggiano via mare.
Ed è evidente che chi controlla i mari
su cui viaggiano
il 90 percento delle merci,
quindi praticamente tutte,
può creare un unico mercato globale.
Gli americani lo hanno fatto
alla fine della guerra fredda,
quando sono rimasti,
per implosione - o suicidio,
fate voi - dell'Unione Sovietica
l'unica superpotenza della Terra
si sono ritrovati
a controllare tutti i mari
e hanno pensato bene di creare
un unico mercato globale.
Facciamo un passo indietro.
Altro pregiudizio che riguarda
la globalizzazione,
se studiata in senso
non strategico, non geopolitico,
è che questo sia un fenomeno inedito.
Noi siamo esseri umani:
i social network
di fatto attestano questo,
crediamo di vivere vite straordinarie.
Altrimenti, perché fotografare
il piatto di pasta che ci mangiamo,
o raccontare di chi ci siamo innamorati,
come se fosse qualcosa di eccezionale?
Allo stesso tempo, siamo convinti
che anche la globalizzazione
sia qualcosa di necessariamente inedito:
non può essere altrimenti,
chi l'ha mai vista?
In realtà,
ce ne sono state almeno un paio
precedenti all'attuale globalizzazione.
Una in senso tecnico,
che era la prima, la "Pax Romana",
la globalizzazione originaria
per eccellenza.
All'epoca bastava il Mediterraneo,
che era di gran lunga
il mare più importante del pianeta;
bastava controllare quello
per creare una globalizzazione.
Cioè, quando i Romani sconfissero,
alla fine della Terza Guerra Punica,
i Cartaginesi,
e controllarono l'intero Mar Mediterraneo,
crearono una globalizzazione
a tutti gli effetti, in senso tecnico.
Cioè divennero dominatori
delle rotte marittime
su cui viaggiano le merci,
e attraverso quelle crearono
un unico mercato, che gestivano.
Dopo i romani ci sono stati i britannici.
La prima globalizzazione
in senso strettamente geografico
è quella britannica:
la "Pax Britannica", per dirla in latino.
Non a caso le globalizzazioni
si chiamano con la dizione latina:
"Pax Romana", "Pax Britannica",
"Pax Americana".
Ad indicare una continuazione,
quindi l'esatto contrario
di qualcosa di inedito,
che invece noi crediamo tale.
All'epoca i britannici,
controllando tutti i mari e oceani,
con la loro eccezionale Marina
crearono la prima
globalizzazione della Storia.
Siamo nella seconda metà dell'800,
in quella che si chiama
"Era Vittoriana", per la Gran Bretagna.
Queste linee blu che vedete
sulla mappa della globalizzazione attuale
non sono altro che le rotte marittime
principali del pianeta,
perché le merci si muovono sul planisfero
non a casaccio, ovviamente.
C'è una necessità di riduzione dei costi:
si deve navigare meno
per spendere meno e arrivare prima,
ci sono rotte marittime
obbligate, tracciate che si seguono,
che sono quelle che vedete in blu.
E sono queste rotte marittime
che controlla la superpotenza,
tutte quante.
In un mondo che,
anche su questo siamo umani,
ci sembra in pieno caos,
ci sembra - non si capisce bene perché,
peraltro - ma ci sembra molto pericoloso.
Due, tre generazioni fa
i nostri nonni, i nostri bisnonni
avrebbero firmato -
e qualcuno che è vivo firmerebbe ancora -
per vivere questa condizione,
anche se noi sembra molto spaventosa.
E invece è molto placida,
specialmente alle nostre latitudini.
Ma se c'è qualcosa
che proprio non cambia -
perché abbiamo l'impressione, anche qui,
che il mondo che viviamo
è in netto cambiamento -
è il controllo di tutti i mari,
e di tutti gli oceani
da parte degli americani.
Questo è proprio inscalfibile,
ormai da diversi decenni,
perché controllano
quelle rotte marittime blu.
In particolare, se vedete
ci sono dei cerchiolini
in quelli che sono gli stretti,
gli istmi del pianeta,
perché ovviamente una potenza
che controlla tutti i mari
e tutti gli oceani,
cosa vuol dire tecnicamente?
Nessuno può controllare,
umanamente, mari e oceani,
chilometro quadrato
per chilometro quadrato:
è impossibile.
Vuol dire controllare
quei passaggi cogenti, ineludibili
che sono gli stretti,
gli istmi del pianeta,
cioè dove le navi
devono necessariamente passare:
le strettoie.
Suez, Gibilterra, Bab-el-Mandeb,
Malacca, Panama.
Ne possiamo citare moltissimi: Hormuz...
Tutti quegli stretti
dove bisogna passare per forza.
E in linea di potenza, gli Stati Uniti
possono interdire il passaggio
a qualsiasi Marina, che sia commerciale
o militare, del pianeta:
qualsiasi, nessuna esclusa.
Lo strapotere marittimo americano
è inattaccabile ancora oggi,
perché gli Stati Uniti, come nel caso
di ogni globalizzazione della Storia,
come è successo ai romani e i britannici,
sono una talassocrazia.
Cioè sono una potenza
principalmente marittima.
Gli americani guardano il mondo dal mare.
Non solo perché - in modo molto violento,
come tutte le grandi potenze -
si sono fatti isola
sterminando o sconfiggendo
le popolazioni vicine.
Oggi vivono di fatto su un'isola,
che è il Nord America,
attaccabili soltanto dagli oceani
e quindi la loro percezione
è sempre marittima;
ma giudicano anche gli altri
dalla capacità o meno di stare in mare.
Perché è così fondamentale,
in qualsiasi dominio assoluto
che poi conduce alla globalizzazione,
avere uno strapotere marittimo?
Perché parliamo del vantaggio
strategico per eccellenza.
Anzitutto perché
le infrastrutture marittime,
come potete capire per semplice inferenza,
esistono in quanto tali:
non devono essere costruite,
non costano niente.
Il mare già c'è: bisogna saperlo navigare.
E non è semplicissimo:
ci si muore di paura, mediamente,
specialmente all'inizio;
ma esiste già l'infrastruttura.
Sul piano strettamente militare,
controllare i mari
vuol dire poter soffocare
qualsiasi nemico che si affaccia sui mari.
Impedire a questo di uscire di casa.
Di dover volgere
le spalle al mare per terrore.
Il terrore del mare è un tema
che riguarda tutte le grandi civiltà
e tutte le grandi potenze,
non sono nella loro fase embrionale,
ma che spesso ne determina il destino.
I britannici, come dicevamo,
hanno creato la globalizzazione
immediatamente precedente a questa,
che finisce intorno
alla Prima Guerra Mondiale.
Sono diventati potenza marittima,
quando non lo erano mai stati.
lo diventano, di fatto,
nel sedicesimo secolo,
a fronte di sforzi disumani,
perché il passaggio da potenza terranea
a potenza marittima
è qualcosa di estremamente disumano,
quasi crudele.
All'epoca, i britannici -
anzi meglio: gli inglesi,
che hanno creato
la loro capacità marittima,
si lanciarono sui flutti per terrore
che qualcuno li venisse ad attaccare,
ancora una volta, dal continente europeo.
Gli attacchi sull'Inghilterra
provenienti dal continente europeo
sono stati una costante
della storia inglese,
al punto da stravolgerne la grammatica;
l'invasione normanna dell'Inghilterra
stravolge la grammatica inglese.
Addirittura,
impone agli inglesi, in alcuni casi,
di porre l'aggettivo dopo il sostantivo:
"Segretario generale"
si dice "Secretary General", in inglese,
perché dal mare arrivarono i Normanni
che imposero una dizione francese
alla grammatica inglese.
Quando la grammatica si stravolge,
la crudeltà è massima.
Quindi, chi controlla le rotte marittime
può non solo creare un mercato globale,
come hanno fatto gli americani,
ma dominare il pianeta
perché ha in sé, fra le sue mani,
lo strumento più capace -
e anche più malvagio -
di cui dispone, ancora oggi,
quando si discute con amenità
di sciocchezze come piazze finanziarie,
oppure telematiche ecc. ecc.
Le questioni che determinano
l'esistenza del pianeta sono queste:
sono essenzialmente concrete,
e viaggiano sull'acqua.
Quello che vediamo qui è un tentativo
di contro-globalizzazione,
l'attuale tentativo
di contro-globalizzazione.
E quindi, entriamo nel tema: quanto durerà
la globalizzazione che viviamo?
A che punto è?
Piccola premessa:
la globalizzazione non c'entra niente
con il libero commercio.
Non solo perché il libero commercio
non esiste, e non è mai esistito:
è pura ideologia,
tutti i paesi del pianeta, da sempre,
applicano dazi su qualcosa
o contro qualcuno.
Tutti, nessuno escluso.
Chi li applica meno
è proprio il perno del sistema,
cioè gli Stati Uniti in questo caso,
così come i romani
o i britannici prima di loro,
perché per creare dipendenza sugli altri
questi paesi importano massicciamente,
perché importando massicciamente
rendono gli altri dipendenti da sé;
e poi, fisicamente,
consegnano la propria moneta
nelle mani di questi.
A qualcuno non va bene, inevitabilmente:
questo qualcuno,
nel tempo presente, è la Cina.
Che non è una potenza marittima,
tantomeno una talassocrazia,
che sta cercando
di sfidare gli Stati Uniti
promuovendo una contro-globalizzazione
che chiama "Via della Seta".
Siccome la Cina tutte queste cose le sa,
dal momento che la Cina
esporta una buona fetta del suo PIL
e lo fa per il 90 percento delle merci
su rotte controllate dagli americani,
capite che la Cina sta
sotto schiaffo degli americani.
Abbiamo l'impressione che la Cina
sia quasi all'offensiva
nei confronti degli Stati Uniti,
specialmente in Italia, dove non brilliamo
esattamente per strategia.
Ma su questo il mare è inesorabile:
ci da una cartina
che ci consente di capire
quali sono i rapporti di forza.
Tradotto: non sono i cinesi
ad insidiare gli americani
nel Golfo del Messico,
ma sono gli americani
che impediscono ai cinesi
di arrivare a Taiwan.
Questa è la distanza fra le due potenze:
la Cina pensa,
attraverso questi corridoi
delle "Vie della Seta",
di sfidare la globalizzazione
Statunitense,
con una dimensione,
quella principale che vedete in alto,
che è soprattutto terrestre.
La Cina intende costruire infrastrutture
che vadano dalla sua costa alla Germania,
sulla terra,
in paesi non esattamente al primato
per quanto riguarda lo sviluppo
economico e civile,
nell'Asia centrale,
perché non potendo controllare i mari
prova ad andare via terra.
I rapporti di forza sono questi.
Poi c'è una dimensione anche marittima,
nelle "Vie della Seta" cinesi,
che è una dimensione utilitaristica:
non di sfida aperta
allo strapotere marittimo americano,
che oggi come dicevo è inscalfibile,
ci serve a determinare
quanto durerà ancora la globalizzazione,
con cui mi avvio alla conclusione.
La Cina, anche quando pensa
a una dimensione marittima
della propria contro-globalizzazione,
lo fa pensando di costruire porti
nell'Oceano Indiano
che poi conducano fino all'Europa,
in particolare nel Mediterraneo,
dove ha già acquistato
il porto del Pireo ad Atene
e vorrebbe mettere le mani -
ma ci sta pensando seriamente -
a Trieste, in Italia.
Perché non potendo andare per mare
in quanto tale, pensa di appoggiarsi.
Come quando si sta sulla spiaggia,
la sabbia scotta e si mettono in piedi,
ogni volta, nell'ombra di un ombrellone.
La Cina prova a farlo costruendo porti
che le consentano di appoggiarsi,
non potendo andare nel mare aperto
per non incontrare
la rappresaglia americana.
Che comunque arriverà, probabilmente,
anche soltanto su questo.
Quindi, a che punto è la globalizzazione?
La globalizzazione non si sta estinguendo
perché Trump impone dazi agli altri.
La globalizzazione
non è il libero commercio:
è il controllo delle rotte marittime
da parte di una sola potenza,
e finirà quando gli americani
non avranno più la capacità, o la forza,
di controllare tutti i mari
e tutti gli oceani
nella maniera in cui vi ho spiegato.
Quando cioè, visto che abbiamo
introdotto la Cina -
che resta un paese ancora terrestre,
sebbene si stia espandendo
in maniera eccezionale
per quanto riguarda i mezzi navali -
quando la Cina sarà in grado
di interdire agli americani
almeno il controllo di un mare rivierasco.
Quando saranno i cinesi
a "balcanizzare", come si dice,
una parte della globalizzazione.
In quel momento,
la globalizzazione per come la conosciamo
finirà, non sarà più tale:
potrà essere una globalizzazione
a tre quarti o a metà,
oppure, semplicemente,
gli Stati Uniti imploderanno,
e lasceranno che il planisfero torni
alla fase precedente alla globalizzazione
che è quella di una divisione
dei mari e dei compiti,
quindi tra "paces" diverse
per quanto riguarda l'ambito marittimo.
Ma ciò che ci serve ricordare
è che quando ci occupiamo
di globalizzazione,
invece di distrarci
con elementi ideologici
riguardanti il libero commercio
o questioni affini,
conviene sempre dare uno sguardo
a quello che capita sui mari,
perché i mari ci dicono a che punto siamo
sulla globalizzazione
e il dominio del pianeta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)